- Say hi to the Fireman.
It's their first time here in America.
- Hi
- Hi Firemen
- Oh wow.
- We, we noticed you.
- Yeah.
Billy joked backstage
that I wore the same
outfit as you guys did.
- He technically did.
- Yeah. But I've never been a Fireman.
I just played one in a Hallmark movie.
- So it's basically the same, right?
- No, no, not at all.
It requires the same level of bravery.
- Yes.
- Did you ever, cause my son, he's six
he's gone through the phase
that he wanted to be a fireman.
Did y'all ever wanna be a
Fireman when you were a kid?
- Yeah. They're like, you know
the greatest heroes in
our society, you know?
- Yeah.
- Aww, that's sweet.
I like that. I like that.
Well, wait, I know that
we've talked before
about your parents and how
much they encouraged you
you know, and that's so cool.
The entertainment world.
Yeah. So did they, I don't know.
How were they like when you were a kid?
Cause you sing in this
- I do.
- And I have to lead with this
cause I'm a singer or whatever.
- Yes.
- You're a singer?
- What? I know.
No, but I just, I had to lead
with it cause I thought it
was so great at the end
when you were singing.
- Thank you.
I was like, I'm sorry Billy.
I didn't know that about you.
- That a big compliment coming from you.
No, it's such great tone, you're vibrato.
- Thank you.
- (Kelly)Yeah.
- Wow. Okay.
- We're talking technique.
- I know.
When I was a kid I opened my mouth
as a young boy and had
a good singing voice.
- (Kelly)Yeah.
- And I grew up in New York City
and I was really lucky cause
my parents loved Broadway.
So they took me to a lot of Broadway.
They took me to see concerts
and they really encouraged me to sing.
- How lucky.
- I was so lucky.
- Yeah.
And it was a, I think
that's why I'm here today
because they were so supportive.
Mm. Yeah.
- I love that.
- Speaking of music, I found out
that you're like a huge Garth Brooks fan.
- I am.
For real.
And that actually ties into
our movie a little bit.
- I know.
So that's where the dance,
you're doing the dance, isn't it?
Like it's a different layer.
- It's an homage to the dance.
- Yes.
- That I see.
- I recognized the song--
- Yes, yes.
- The melody. Yeah.
- Which you sang--
- Brilliantly.
- You're version of the
dance was absolutely.
- Oh, at the Kennedy Center, thank you.
- Oh my gosh.
- You made Garth Brooks cry
- (Kelly) Aw, thank you.
- And everybody watching you.
- I watched that like 30 times.
- (Kelly) Thank you.
- Literally during the
filming we were talking a lot
about Garth Brooks
and and Billy actually wrote that song
during the filming of it.
- Oh, really?
It was not something
that was totally planned.
- Yeah.
- It came out of a conversation
that we had about --
- Yeah.
- What music we like.
- Yeah. Because we didn't
know each other before
we started shooting.
- (Kelly) Yeah.
- And we were trying to
get to know each other.
So I said to him, you know,
what kind of music do you like?
And he said, actually
I love country music.
And my favorite singer is Garth Brooks.
And I was thinking my character
in the movie at the end
I don't want to give it
all away, but you know
he needs to make a grand gesture.
- (Kelly) Yeah.
- You know, cause he's
in love with this guy
but has a hard time expressing himself.
We both do.
That's what Bros is about.
And I thought, you know
what I, I like the idea
of a gay man singing a Garth
Brooks inspired country song,
a love song, to the guy he's in love with.
Even though my character
doesn't love country music
but his does.
So that's part of the gesture.
- Yeah.
- You have great taste in real life.
I'm just saying.
- (Billy)Thank you very much.
- I, I noticed you liked country
so I gave you George Strait vinyl.
- Yes.
- Just saying, dip into that.
- Absolutely. Amarillo By Morning.
Oh yes.
- (Kelly)Oh my gosh. Its so good.
- He's a real country fan.
- I actually tried to play
it on your record player.
Your record player
backstage was not working.
- It was not working.
It was not working for me.
- We like to just give
you the vinyl to look at.
- Oh, well I took it out cause
I wanted to get it going.
- We will now fix that.
- Uh, yes.
Heads will roll at the
Kelly Clarkson Show.
- No, no, no, they're like,
what was wrong with the needle?
Anyway, so like what
musical artist did you
grow up listening to?
- I'm a little different, you
know, that's what's great.
He was a, a gay guy that
loved country music.
I grew up in New York City,
you know, I loved Madonna.
You know, I, I loved Barbara Streisand.
My parents took me to
see Barbara Streisand.
- Oh, you've seen her live?
- In concert in 1994.
I was like 14.
It was her big, it was like
her first tour in 25 years.
- (Luke) Wow.
- Bragger.
- I know.
I I remember it vividly to this day.
I mean, we sat high up.
I mean the tickets were very expensive.
- You were in the room!
- I was in the room with Barbara.
- Yeah. I've never been in the room.
That's amazing.
- It was amazing.
- Yeah. Oh my gosh.
Billy, you're making
history with this movie
and it was almost an entirely
LGBTQ plus cast and crew.
So how does it feel now
that the movie's closer
to being released?
Are you, I bet there's a
little bit of nerves involved.
- Of course.
I mean, you'd be crazy
not to be nervous, but--
- Yeah.
- But, you know, we all
love the movie so much.
It's very rare.
Almost the entire cast is
all openly LGBTQ actors,
even playing the straight characters,
which very rarely happens.
Although, except for
some celebrity cameos.
Thank you.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- We do have some very
fun celebrity cameos.
Deborah Messing from Will and Graces.
- (Kelly) Oh my God, love her.
- Absolutely hilarious in this.
Kristin Chenoweth and a bunch of others.
I don't want to give it away.
But yeah, it was it was very special.
And you know, but a comedy
is a comedy, you know
it was produced by Judd Apatow,
who's made some of the
funniest comedies ever.
- (Kelly) Yeah.
- Bridesmaids and 40 year Old Virgin
and Knocked Up and Train Wreck.
- (Kelly)Yeah.
- And Nick Stahl directed it
he made Forgetting Sarah Marshall.
But we've never had a movie
like that, like a big, you know
studio comedy about gay couples.
- (Luke)Yeah.
And so that's what this is.
But you know, if you're,
if you like comedy
you're gonna like it
whether you're straight gay
or no matter what you are.
- (Luke) Yeah.
- Yeah. I It's just funny.
Funny. It's
- Funny. Yeah.
So, wait, so this was,
Luke this was your first time
auditioning for a studio film.
Right?
- It was my first time auditioning
for a lead in a studio film.
- (Kelly) Okay. A lead in a studio film.
- Yes. Yes.
- It went well.
I, I'm still pinching myself.
Yeah, it's great.
It's nerve-wrecking.
I think, you know, as an
actor, you, you always
want to do the big movies,
but they seem so hard to get
you know, the truth is it's
a very competitive business
- (Kelly) Yeah.
- As it turns out.
So yeah.
I'm lucky it went well.
And I'm lucky that a part came along
that just made so much
sense for me to inhabit.
- But speaking of parts of you also
you play straight a lot,
on like Hallmark films.
- I do, yes.
Hallmark has been very good to me
and I really enjoy working with Hallmark.
- (Kelly) Yeah.
- And yeah, I've made
about 13 Hallmark movies.
A lot of Christmas movies.
- (Kelly) Yeah.
- I mean it's all, it's all acting.
Everyone's acting regardless.
But what, how, what's y'all take
on people like, on representation,
you know what I'm saying?
So if people are gay,
playing a straight person
or straight playing a gay
person, what's your take on it?
- Well, I just saw this morning
Hallmark is doing a
Hanukkah movie this year
and I wasn't called and
I'm furious you know.
- I am writing a stern letter.
- Yeah, please, please
write to them, okay.
You know, look, I mean,
acting is an art form
you know, you know, it's not like,
oh gay can only play gay
and straight can only play straight.
- (Kelly) Yeah.
But you know, historically,
most of the high profile LGBTQ
roles we've seen in movies,
those roles are often played
by straight movie stars.
And some of them have
been amazing, you know
of course they've been magnificent.
But we would like an
opportunity to star movies too,
you know.
- (Kelly) Yeah.
We've never really gotten that.
Especially in a big
funny comedy like this.
And so we're just trying to, you know
correct that imbalance a little bit
and give new people an
opportunity to shine.
- Yeah.
- I agree with that.
- Well in the movie Billy's
character struggles to date.
So have either of you
really had a terrible date?
You're lying if you say no.
- Oh, definitely, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I had a date recently
where the guy worked
for a Cannabis company,
which is totally fine.
Yeah. I'm like, what's the problem?
- No, no, no.
I think I heard a yeah!
- Yeah, but, well he just
showed up extremely high.
- Oh, no.
- Like extremely stoned
and made it impossible to communicate.
You know what I mean.
- Yeah. It was Seth Rogen .
- But you know, dating is tough.
That's what we deal with in the movie.
Like, our characters are
both almost competing
when they meet to see who's
more emotionally unavailable.
- Yeah.
- You know, like you see
in that text exchange
they both really like each other
but no one wants to make the first move.
Everyone's being too cool for school.
And that's like
texting has allowed us to
all be so passive aggressive
with each other and dating apps
and DMing on Instagram
and you know, we used all
of our personal experiences
and put those into the movie.
- I, I've been talking
about bad dates and it's
it's not one specific,
I've been on so many dates
where the person is still on the phone
and they're looking at the phone.
Cause I think we forget
what it's like to be in
what's the, IRL.
- Oh, in real life.
- In real life.
- Oh my god.
People literally do that.
- Yeah. And then they're like, just sorry,
it's like really important.
And you know
you gotta glance, and you're
like, that's your Instagram.
- Basically said that you're not.
Like this is really important.
You're less important.
Give me a minute.
Wow.
- Yeah
- Yeah. That's bad.